ساعات عصيبه في منطقه بيلجورودا الروسيه
المتاخمه للحدود مع اوكرانيا فمره اخرى
تدفع المدينه ضريبه الجغرافيا لتكون في
مهب تداعيات الحرب هرع السكان الى الشوارع
ودبت الفوضى وتتالت البيانات المحليه ومن
موسكو
قعوا بالجرود جنوب غربي روسيا على الحدود
مع اوكرانيا وتقول الروايه الروسيه ان
مجموعه تخريبيه اوكرانيه هاجمت المنطقه
وتصدت لها تشكيلات من مختلف القوات
المرابطه هناك
حاكم بيلجورود اكد سقوط قتلى وجرح في
الهجمات التي طاولت ثلاثه قرى في المنطقه
واكد قيام السلطات باجلاء السكان كما اعلن
ادراج بيجرود ضمن النظام القانوني لمنطقه
عمليات مكافحه الارهاب ويمنح ذلك النظام
السلطات صلاحيه اجلاء المدنيين ومراقبه
اكبر للاتصالات والتحقق من وثائق الاشخاص
والمركبات وقد سرعت اوكرانيا الى نفي
مسؤوليتها عن حادث التوغل اذ اعلن مستشار
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان كيف تتابع باهتمام
الاحداث في منطقه بيلكورود في روسيا وتدرس
الوضع لكن لا علاقه لها بذلك
فيما يخص ما يجري على اراضي الاتحاد
الروسي نحن نرى الانحلال والاضطرابات التي
تجري منذ بدء الاعمال العدائيه والاعتداء
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه اعتقد ان هذه
الاحداث ستزيد ليس فقط في منطقه بل ايضا
في كافه الاراضي الروسيه وعلى خط البيانات
والبيانات المضاده دخلت مجموعه تسمي نفسها
فيلق حريه روسيا معلنه مسؤوليتها عن هجوم
بيلجورود فهل يتعلق الامر فعلا بتحول في
الحرب ونقل المعركه الى داخل الاراضي
الروسيه ام انه لا يتعدى مجرد حادثه عابره
يحلو الكريم التقليل منها وادراجها ضمن
محاوله اوكرانيا لصرف الانتباه عن خسارتها
مدينه بخموت اخيرا